cargo 200 en russe vesti c'est le nom
que les Soviétiques ont donné au
ramassage des morts en Afghanistan dans
les années 80 et c'est resté en Ukraine
aussi le nombre de sang est inscrit sur
le camion 200 kg c'est le poids d'un
corps dans un cercueil en zinc
avec le chien qui porte aussi le 200
Larissa borisenko de l'ONG Antares se
consacre à la recherche des soldats
Ukrainiens morts avec l'unité
spécialisée de l'armée ukrainienne
il est très important de récupérer les
corps ils ont tous droit à une sépulture
correcte ces soldats morts combien
sont-ils dans cette guerre après neuf
mois du côté des militaires c'est très
compliqué d'avoir des estimations parce
que évidemment les chiffres sont cachés
et aucun des deux protagonistes ne
communiquent très clairement depuis
toujours secret d'état stratégiques
alors Xavier titlemmann se bat sur des
données précises et documentées comme
celle du site oryx on sait que les
Russes ont perdu quasiment 8000
véhicules donc certainement qu'il y en a
peut-être 10 000 qui ont été perdus mais
on a les photos de quasiment 8000
véhicules détruits or traditionnellement
on sait qu'il y a entre 6 et 8 morts par
véhicule perdus donc on aura entre 60 et
80000 soldats russes qui seraient mort
sur le terrain plus tous les blessés qui
sont encore derrière les chiffres
officiels Ukrainiens donnent plus de 85
000 morts russes probablement exagéré
autre repère le nombre d'officiers
russes tués et
identifié si bien qu'on a plus de 1500
officiers russes qui ont été identifiés
et on a généralement un ratio qui peut
être environ de 30 donc c'est à dire que
pour un officier vous avez 30 soldats
durant ce qui fait à peu près encore une
fois 45000 et là ce n'est que le ratio
par rapport aux officiers qui sont
connus donc certainement que le chiffre
de 60 000 est tout à fait crédible les
Russes eux ne donnent aucun chiffre et
les Ukrainiens de disent rien de leur
perte
du côté ukrainien on a des estimations
mais qui sont bizarrement moins précises
notamment parce que ils ont perdu
beaucoup moins de matériel notamment
dans le début de l'invasion les
Ukrainiens étaient moins armés donc il y
a moins d'équipements néanmoins
traditionnellement une armée qui fait
des offensives ratées et c'est ce que la
Russie a fait pendant très longtemps
subit plus de pertes que le défenseur
donc logiquement on estime que rien
entre 45000 50 000 soldats Ukrainiens
qui seraient mort depuis le début
quand au nombre de victimes civiles tout
ukrainienne bien sûr les Nations Unies
les estiment après de 7000 dont près de
600 enfants il y en a probablement
davantage avec en plus presque 8
millions de réfugiés un peu partout en
Europe
les Russes ont perdu en 9 mois au moins
3 fois plus de soldats qu'en Afghanistan
en 10 ans d'une guerre qui a mal fini
pour Moscou la grande question est pour
l'Ukraine quel est le seuil de tolérance
du Kremlin et du peuple russe
Jean-Michel le prince du Canada Montréal